uh by air
by sea
and as i noted in my remarks uh at the
u.n human rights council just yesterday
russian strikes are hitting schools
hospitals
residences
they're destroying critical
infrastructure which supplies millions
of people across ukraine
with drinking water with electricity
with gas to keep from freezing to death
buses
cars
ambulances
being shelled
yesterday
russian strikes in kiev struck the
capital's main television and radio
tower
and destroyed part of the babajar
holocaust
memorial apartment buildings outside of
kyiv were hit
partially collapsed
a huge explosion occurred in the main
square of kharkiv
ukraine's second largest city
these aren't military targets
they are places where civilians work
and families live
parkiva is one of the largest
russian-speaking cities in europe
it's fewer than
50 miles from belgarad it's sister city
in russia
and belgarot is where the missiles
against tarkiv were likely fired
president putin among the many
false justifications
he's given for invading ukraine
has cited the need to protect against an
imaginary threat
to
russian ethnic and
russian-speaking peoples
how is assaulting and bombing
the population of harkief
again one of the largest
russian-speaking cities in europe
advancing that purported goal
as president zielinski said after the
assault
there was never a border between
kharkiv and its russian sister city
two cities are joined in the hearts of
ukrainian and russian people
living on either side
among the
great damage we see from war uh we're
seeing that uh in in our kiev
we've also seen that
the international court of justice has
announced that it will hold hearings
on russia's actions
already the human costs of the kremlin's
unwarranted
unprovoked and unjustified war on
ukraine
are staggering
hundreds if not thousands of civilians
have been killed and wounded
there are now more than 174 000 refugees
who sought safety in nearby countries
millions of ukrainians still in ukraine
are sheltering wherever they can
including children receiving cancer
treatment
who are now living in the basements of
ukraine's children's hospitals with
doctors and nurses doing their best to
care for them as explosions boom
overhead
this is shameful
the numbers of civilians killed and
wounded humanitarian consequences will
only grow in the days ahead
in the face of this violence the courage
of the ukrainian people
is inspiring the world
as president biden said in the state of
the union address last night
the response to russia's war has been
unity
unity among world leaders
unity in europe
unity among
people gathering around the world
to protest president putin's war of
choice
including thousands of people in russia
and belarus
coming out to protest peacefully
even though they know what they risk in
so doing
because the biden administration
dedicated its first year
to repairing and rebuilding our
alliances and partnerships in europe and
around the world
and because we spent the better part of
the past several months
raising alarms about looming russian
aggression
declassifying and sharing our
intelligence uh nearly in real time
and relentlessly exposing president
putin's lies
we were ready
in fact
one reason uh why we're seeing the
unified response now
is because we made the decision late
last year to publicize to the world
what we knew was underway and the
playbook we were convinced russia would
follow
i went to the un security council two
weeks ago
to walk through step by step
the pretext for war that
we were sure president putin would
invent
and the subsequent military invasion
that he planned to order
that's precisely what he did
while russian officials continued to
deny it right until the invasion began
seeing that duplicity and premeditated
aggression play out exactly as we'd
predicted
has generated outrage and solidarity
across europe and around the world and
that's turned into unprecedented action
we said that
if the kremlin ordered an invasion
uh we would help ukraine defend itself
while imposing costs on russia
last week the president approved 350
million dollars in military assistance
to ukraine to help uh with the armored
airborne and other significant threats
it now faces
that brings our total security
assistance to ukraine in the past year
to more than one billion dollars
more than in any previous year
over the past several days
i authorized the expedited transfer of
u.s origin defensive equipment
from allies to ukraine
and we're coordinating efforts to get
this equipment
including anti-tank and anti-aircraft
weaponry as well as small arms and
munitions into the hands of ukrainian
fighters who are defending their country
with skill
and determination
we're sending humanitarian assistance to
the people of ukraine as well
three days ago we announced nearly 54
million dollars in additional support on
top of the more than 300 million dollars
that we've provided in recent years
usaid has deployed a disaster assistance
response team our top international
emergency responders to lead the u.s
humanitarian response in coordination
with european allies partners and
international organizations and usaid
director
samantha power was as you know just in
poland along the border with ukraine a
few days ago
along with other senior officials from
the state department
and we're working to support the front
line countries
including poland moldova romania hungary
and slovakia that have welcomed hundreds
of thousands of refugees including many
children elderly people
people with disabilities all of whom are
fleeing ukraine to escape russia's
violence
and facing harrowing journeys to reach
safety
we and our allies and partners will work
to keep people safe
manage the flow of refugees
keep water crossings open
and provide critical supplies
at the same time
we're holding russia accountable
including russia's economy
back on december 1st
i said that russia would face massive
consequences for attacking ukraine
including severe and lasting economic
the united states and more than 30
allies and partners representing more
than half the world's economy have made
good on that commitment
with powerful sanctions and export
controls on russia including additional
actions just today
we've now sanctioned most of russia's
largest financial institutions and its
sovereign wealth fund
the european union removed key
sanctioned russian banks from the swift
international payments network
we've restricted russia's ability to
seek funding beyond its borders
thirteen of the most critical russian
state-owned enterprises including
gasprom
are now extremely limited in raising
money through the u.s market
we've imposed sanctions on individuals
including president putin
other members of russia's security
council
and elites and their family members
and we and our allies and partners
are launching a task force
to identify track down and freeze the
assets
of sanctioned russian companies and
oligarchs
we will freeze and seize their yachts
their private jets their opulent estates
in world capitals
today we're also imposing sweeping
sanctions on russia's defense sector
in total
22 russian defense-related entities will
be designated
including companies that make combat
aircraft
infantry fighting vehicles missiles
unmanned aerial vehicles electronic
warfare systems the very systems now
being used to assault the ukrainian
people
abuse human rights violate international
humanitarian law
we're also imposing export controls on
belarus
to hold the lukashenko regime
accountable for being a co-belligerent
in president putin's war of choice
we will choke off belarus's ability to
import key technologies
and if lukashenka's support for the war
continues
the consequences for regime
will escalate
all told
these sanctions and restrictions have
had a powerful effect on russia's
economy
the value of the ruble has plummeted
the russian stock market closed at uh as
fear of capital flight rose
interest rates more than doubled
russia's credit rating has been cut to
junk status
the value of president putin's war fund
has vanished
and by choking russia's access to
technology
we're delivering a blow to its economy
and military
that will be felt not just now
but for years to come
president putin may have assumed that
the united states and our allies
were bluffing when we warned of massive
unprecedented consequences
but
as president biden likes to say
big nations can't bluff
the united states doesn't bluff
and president putin has gravely
miscalculated
as president biden made clear last night
this is president putin's war
this isn't the russian people's war
it's becoming clear by the day
that the russian people oppose it
members of the russian military oppose
it
and had no idea
what they were being sent to do
and now the russian people will suffer
the consequences of their leaders
choices
so
my message to the people of russia
if they're even able to hear it as the
kremlin tracks down even harder on media
outlets reporting the truth
my message is that we know
many of you want no part of this war
you
like ukrainians like americans like
people everywhere want the same basic
things
good jobs
clean air and water
the chance to raise your kids in safe
neighborhoods to send them to good
schools
to give them better lives than you had
how in the world does president putin's
unprovoked aggression against ukraine
help you achieve any of these things
how is it going to make your lives
better
the economic costs that we've been
forced to impose on russia are not aimed
at you they're aimed at compelling your
government to stop its actions to stop
its aggression
and just as millions of us around the
world stand together against moscow's
aggression
we also stand together with you as you
demand
that your leaders end this war
if president putin wants to demonstrate
leadership
he should allow russian soldiers to go
home to their families
finally
the united states is continuing our
diplomatic efforts
we're keeping the door open
to a diplomatic way forward
that's going to be very hard to happen
uh without military de-escalation
it's much more difficult for diplomacy
to succeed
when guns are firing tanks are rolling
planes are flying
but
if russia pulls back and pursues
diplomacy
we stand ready to do the same thing
meanwhile
our intensive diplomacy with allies and
partners continues
i've been in virtually daily contact
with my
my friend
and counterpart ukraine's foreign
minister caleb
and i've made clear that we'll support
any diplomatic efforts by the ukrainian
government to reach a ceasefire and
withdrawal of russian forces
if there are diplomatic steps that we
can take that the ukrainian government
believes would be helpful
we're prepared to take them
even as we continue
to support ukraine's ability to defend
itself
tomorrow
i'll travel to brussels where i'll meet
with our nato
european union and g7 allies and
partners
to continue our coordination
to commend them on the unprecedented
steps that they've taken to support
ukraine and hold russia to account
and to reaffirm our article 5 commitment
that an attack on any nato member
is an attack on all
from there i'll travel to poland which
is already hosting hundreds of thousands
of ukrainian refugees
uh with tens of thousands arriving by
the day
and then to moldova
which is also hosting ukrainian refugees
and where russian troops have been
occupying territory against the will of
the people for years
uh and then i'll go on to the baltic
countries to latvia lithuania estonia
which are facing a renewed threat from
russia themselves as president putin
seeks to reassert russia's dominance
over former soviet republics
lafayette lithuania estonia are our nato
allies
and as president biden has said
we will defend every inch of nato
territory against any aggression from
russia or otherwise
finally
i want to note the consequential and
historic vote that just took place in
the united nations
141
member states
voted in favor of a resolution
reaffirming ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity and condemning
russia's invasion of another member
state
as this vote revealed
the overwhelming majority of the
international community stands in strong
support of the core principles of the
united nations and upholding the un
charter
and stands against russia's reckless
attempts to change the borders of
another sovereign country by force
to replace its will for the will of the
ukrainian people
as 141 member states of the united
nations know
more is at stake even than the conflict
in ukraine itself and the freedom and
security of ukraine and its people
this is a threat to stability in europe
and to the entire rules-based order
which has been the foundation of
security and prosperity for people
around the world for nearly 80 years
in
this time of uncertainty
we have a clear way forward
help ukraine defend itself
support the ukrainian people
hold russia accountable
and persist with diplomacy
president putin is more isolated from
the world than ever before
as president biden predicted last night
when the history of this era is written
russia's war on ukraine will have left
russia weaker
and the rest of the world stronger
and in the days ahead
we'll continue to draw inspiration
from the iron will of the ukrainian
people
with that happy to take some questions
thanks for being here um i just want to
ask you what is the us assessment on
putin's state of mind you said that he's
more isolated than before
do you worry that this isolation might
prompt him to lash out and do something
even more dramatic than we've so far
seen on the ground
and i also want to ask you
i'm sure you've seen that
there are americans who have expressed
um their desire to go and join the
fights in ukraine what is your message
to them
thank you thanks um
i can't
put myself in in president putin's uh
mind or or state of mind um
all that that we can focus on are the
actions uh that he's taking
and our response to those actions
um
i said before
one of the
achilles heels of autocracies
is
the
inability
to speak truth to power
i don't know who said what to president
putin
before he launched this aggression i
don't know who's saying what to him now
but again all of that is
speculation
we can't put ourselves in his mindset
all we can do
is what we're doing which is to be very
clear
in how we'll uh respond to the actions
that he takes
to
continue to
work
in unity with allies and partners in
support of ukraine in defense of ukraine
to help its people to host to help those
who've been forced to flee
and if there are any diplomatic
opportunities to pursue to pursue those
but we're focused
less on what president putin thinks or
may think
and more on what he does
um and with regard to the second part of
your question look we've been uh very
clear for some time of course in calling
on americans who may be
they've been resident in ukraine
to leave
and making clear to
americans who may be thinking of
traveling there not to go for those who
want to help ukraine
and help its people there are many
ways to do that uh including by uh
supporting and helping the many ngos
that are working to provide humanitarian
assistance uh providing uh resources
themselves to uh
to groups that are trying to help uh
ukraine by being advocates
uh for for ukraine uh and um and for a
peaceful resolution
uh to this um
crisis that was created by uh by russia
uh
those are the most effective ways that
the people who want to help can do so
mr secretary
you just voted the president saying big
nations don't bluff
do you think that
president putin is bluffing by putting
his nuclear forces on alert
and i had another
question if you don't mind
are you surprised that we have not seen
more
we've seen some denial of services but
are you surprised that we have not seen
a more massive cyber attack against
ukraine or against other of the the nato
nations or against us
do you think that the legislation that
just passed improves
our ability to defend against such
attacks and if i could
impose on you one more question i talked
today to daria galenyak who was part of
the president in your democracy
summit this year
and you know how passionate she is
perhaps you saw
her questioning and she says that
despite everything that has been done
and
i would
i would say it's
an extraordinary amount of coordination
and agreement with the allies it's not
going to get there in time
that convoy is sitting outside kiev
and
poised to encircle
and they're not going to get those
supplies
what more can be done to help those
people
hendra thank you um
let me take them in uh not quite reverse
order uh first just on the uh the cyber
piece uh two things first yes the
legislation that you refer to is
extremely helpful
but beyond that and before that
we have been very focused on the
potential for
cyber attacks
not only against ukraine but against us
against allies and partners
we've been working for months
first with ukraine
and also among ourselves
to uh to harden uh to sharpen defenses
all of that work is very much underway
including with the private sector
and so i think we have to be very much
on guard about that that possibility uh
we are
um
with regard to assistance to ukraine
here's what i can here's what i can tell
you
um we are
very
actively
working
every
day
every hour to
provide that assistance
and uh to
make sure that uh to the best of our
ability it gets to where it needs to go
um and this is not just us this is um
many countries in europe
we're
coordinating a lot of efforts to do that
and my own assessment right now is that
the vitally needed assistance is
getting to where it needs to go
um
with regard to
president putin's statements on
russia's nuclear posture
uh first as you know um
russia and the united states have long
agreed
that
the actual use of nuclear weapons would
be devastating
and have devastating consequences
for the entire world
and as we've stated many times including
earlier this year
following the meeting between president
biden and president putin in geneva
both of our countries have stated that a
nuclear war cannot be won and must never
be fought
that was a key reaffirmation coming out
of the meeting between president biden
president putin back in june
provocative rhetoric about
nuclear weapons
is the height of your responsibility
it's dangerous
it adds to the risk of miscalculation
it needs to be avoided
we've assessed president putin's
directive and his statements
and at this time we see
no reason
to change our own alert levels
thanks
mr secretary thank you um i i you
mentioned the vote in the u.n which was
by you know it was overwhelming as as
you said and uh the the countries that
voted against the five countries who
voted against no surprise belarus
eritrea north korea syria and of russia
but i'm wondering if you have any
thoughts about the abstentions
particularly from latin america
cuba nicaragua venezuela who stayed out
these are countries that are no stranger
to
larger powers who might shall go
unnamed uh getting involved in
in their internal policy i'm wondering
if that says anything to you and then
secondly um on the prospects for
diplomacy with russia which you said
you're keeping the door open to i mean
really what are the what are the
prospects for what are the chances of
that happening in our and and and
is there
if there is an open door is it just for
ukraine
uh and potentially the iran talks in
vienna or are are you
open to
the whole gamut of things the arms
control
climate uh
you know any number of other things
thank you
um
matt first of all to put the the vote in
the u.n um
in perspective um
it is
both overwhelming and i would even say
historic uh go back to 2014
when the general assembly pronounced
itself on russia's initial aggression
against ukraine
uh the votes in favor of that resolution
uh were 100
um
then go to uh the horrific
actions that the assad regime took
in aleppo
the vote there was 120 in favor of a
resolution
uh condemning
the actions of the the assad regime
today
141 votes
um that speaks powerfully and eloquently
about
the overwhelming majority of the world
and uh its views about what russia is
doing in ukraine
uh
i'm not going to parse the
the the individual votes i think
um
in some cases an abstention actually
speaks loudly
itself
um as opposed to a no vote
so i think you have to look at some of
the individual countries
assess their
relationship with russia
and look at how they voted in that
context
for the small number
that voted against belarus
the dprk uh eritrea
syria as well as of course russia
as uh
groucho marx once sort of said this is
not very much a club that i would want
to be a member of
oh wait sorry on the the prospects for
deposition oh i'm sorry yes um
look as i said
uh
a moment ago
with regard to ukraine itself
we of course uh remain open to pursuing
any uh reasonable path but it's very
hard to see any path
when the bonds are dropping the planes
are flying the tanks are rolling so
de-escalation pulling back forces
that would open a path to diplomacy and
and we
i think demonstrated very clearly in the
uh in the months leading up to russia's
aggression
that we were prepared to engage uh
russia diplomatically on uh
any legitimate security concerns uh on a
reciprocal basis
that remains unfortunately
tragically horrifically i think we've
seen
and you don't have to take my word for
it just listen to president putin's own
words
that
virtually everything the
russian government professed
uh to be concerned about was not really
what was at issue for example ukraine
joining nato what president putin has
said
loudly and clearly and has now
demonstrated by the actions that russia
has taken
is that what this is about
for him
uh is um
ukraine being absorbed in one fashion or
another into russia
he sees ukraine as having no independent
existence
uh he wants uh to
reincorporate it into uh uh into an
empire short of that
to make it part of a renewed sphere of
influence
uh or maybe at the very least
uh to uh to make it totally uh neutral
so this is
um about
way more than
the uh
issues uh that we were
prepared to engage restaurants so
two two quick pieces on the diplomacy
now one with regard to ukraine itself
first and foremost uh the the question
is if ukraine thinks there is
uh a path that would help uh advance its
interests
uh protect it and the war and we can be
helpful in that of course
we're fully prepared to do that uh but
uh we really look to um uh the ukrainian
government to see what um what if
anything might make sense uh that
they're
engaged in uh uh in talks with with
russia they had one round uh there may
be another one we'll see um but of
course the uh the
demands that russia put on the table
uh were
uh
beyond excessive they were of course
non-starters and what we've seen
repeatedly is that russia goes through
the pretense of diplomacy to distract
and continue
it on its aggressive path
more broadly
even as we've imposed um and continue to
impose massive costs on russia for its
aggression and actions in ukraine if we
determine that there are areas that uh
it's in our interest
to continue to pursue um and uh that in
one fashion or other may involve some
engagement for russia uh we'll continue
to pursue that we're not gonna let
russia dictate
in any way what's in our interests and
how to pursue them
media ukraine um just a few days ago
european union proposed to donate their
fighter jets to ukraine to protect our
sky but as far as they know for now this
deal has fallen apart i know that you
were in a phone call with foreign
minister coleman today discussing with
this topic as well could one expect that
after after your travel to europe
something could change and ukraine will
get access to those jets
thank you um i
i can't comment in detail in my
conversations with foreign minister
khalifa we uh we talked about a lot of
things including
uh the ongoing provision of security
assistance to uh to ukraine uh and that
is something that i will be talking to
european allies and uh and partners
about in a couple of days in in brussels
uh again i can tell you is
um i mentioned in response to andrea's
question that when it comes to vital uh
defensive military equipment uh that uh
that ukraine needs uh we are very uh
actively coordinating its provision and
that assistance is uh is getting there
but we'll probably have more to say in
the next couple of days thank you thank
you very much thanks everyone thank you
very much
sir do you think that russia is
deliberately targeting civilians you
said they're hitting schools and
hospitals
are they doing it deliberately
we've certainly seen uh in the past that
um
one of russia's methods of war
uh is
to be absolutely brutal
in trying to
cow the citizenry
uh of um of a given country
and that includes
at the very least
indiscriminate
targeting
and potentially deliberate targeting as
well
we're looking very closely at uh what's
happening in ukraine right now
including what's happening to uh to
civilians
uh we're taking account of it
we're documenting it
and we want to ensure among other things
that there's accountability for it
thank you thank you mr secretary
you